so the Democratic primary is taking very
interesting shape over the last 10 days
and the stories have big picture been
Bernie climbing Bloomberg climbing Biden
falling with Bernie taking the lead and
last week Michael Bloomberg passing Pete
Budaj edge and getting into third place
and as you know I've been saying that
despite the very damaging audio and
video of Michael Bloomberg which heavily
publicizes lately his horribly
insensitive comments about stop and
frisk and race I have been saying that
Bloomberg is going to end up doing way
better than anybody was thinking when he
entered this race and case in point
breaking news we have a new poll with
Michael Bloomberg and second place
qualifying qualifying for tomorrow's
debate in Nevada ahead of the Nevada
caucuses the poll is an NPR PBS Marist
Poll of 1,400 adults it has Bernie
Sanders with an even bigger lead than
we've previously seen Bloomberg in
second place let's look at the poll
results Bernie at 31% a massive lead
over Bloomberg at 19% in second place
Biden in third at 15 Warren in fourth at
12 Clovis Shar in fifth with 9 and in
this poll mayor Pete has fallen to sixth
place with 8% of the vote a complete
reversal from his recent momentum in
Iowa and New Hampshire Bernie in this
poll since December gaining 9 points
Bloomberg gaining 15 since December and
the biggest loser Biden going from 24 in
this same poll back in December losing 9
points to 15 so let's talk about the
Bloomberg stuff a little bit there's
been a major online effort to attack
Michael Bloomberg as this racist
oligarch buying his way into the
election which is not a completely
inaccurate framing but it may not be
working I said early last week when our
good friend Ben Dixon publicized this
horrible stop-and-frisk audio that it
may not have a signature
in effect on Michael Bloomberg's support
and so far his support at least in this
poll has continued to increase now I
don't believe Michael Bloomberg will be
the nominee but he is going to be a
factor in determining who the nominee is
even if it's merely by picking up just
enough delegates to prevent Bernie
Sanders from getting the nomination
which may be increasingly the role for
Michael Bloomberg as the Democratic
establishment may see it but what is
important in the immediate in terms of
how this changes the dynamic of the race
is that Michael Bloomberg has now
qualified for the debate in Nevada just
as we predicted he would based on the
rule changes from the DNC which remove
individual donors as a fund rate as a
qualification criteria and now not only
do you have Michael Bloomberg spending
but according to one report is more than
300 million dollars pouring it into ads
all over the place internet television
radio I'm not sure about but possibly
radio you now will have that money
continuing to pour in and Michael
Bloomberg on the debate stage ahead of
Nevada giving voters across the country
their first look at Bloomberg in a
debate now if he doesn't do well in the
debate this may be self-destructive if
you believe that he will show up with at
least more energy than Biden and maybe
getting more speaking time than Warren
and Budaj edge based on the recent
polling it's conceivable that the
combination of Bloomberg at the debate
and Bloomberg continuing to pour
hundreds of millions of dollars in is
going to continue giving him lift
meanwhile the next primary is as I
mentioned the Nevada caucus it's on
Saturday
the very good news for Bernie Sanders
there are two new polls this month
Bernie ahead in both Bernie leading by
19 in Nevada in the latest DF people 35
to 16 over second place Elizabeth Warren
and Bernie leading by 7 in the Las Vegas
Review Journal poll 25 to 18 and then
lastly in our look at the polls in South
Carolina Biden as of now still in the
lead Bernie ins second Tom Steyer in
third steyr needs some delegates there
in order to justify continuing past
February 29th which is when South
Carolina will vote
otherwise Tom Steyer should likely exit
before Super Tuesday so there are two
movements that are getting very agitated
right now you have the establishment
stop Burnie movement they're trying to
figure out what's their best bet it's
clear that supporting Joe Biden was not
the right bet Biden now polling fourth
even fifth in some places so do they
move their support from Biden to Mayor
Pete do they consider amy klobuchar do
they abandon the sort of centrist
establishment Democrats altogether and
go to Bloomberg who is a Republican for
much of the last 20 years and meanwhile
you have a stop Bloomberg movement from
those who have realized that Bloomberg's
massive polling gains may end up being
what prevents Bernie not from getting a
plurality of the delegates he still may
but what prevents Bernie from getting
50% plus one which is what's required to
secure the nomination and prevent
super-delegates from getting to vote at
the DNC right now the
fivethirtyeight.com odds for the
Democratic nomination are even money
between Bernie securing the nomination
versus no one securing the nomination
and thus forcing a contested convention
2 and 5 odds for both followed by a
Biden nomination as the next most likely
scenario at 12% the next 14 days will
tell us probably 90% of what we need to
know about this Democratic nomination
process I believe that by Super Tuesday
which is two weeks from today by the end
of Super Tuesday we will be able to say
with 90% certainty what the future of
the Democratic nomination this year is
going to be privacy calm is one of our
sponsors and they're giving you $5.00
just for using their free service at
privacy calm slash Pakman privacy's of
service I've been using for a while now
I love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free and it's
very quick to set up and here's how it
works when you pay for something online
or over the phone instead of exposing
your real credit card number privacy
lets you generate virtual card numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and
you do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft it costs you nothing and
privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman